the spider-man far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers end game yet
stop watching because there's some
serious spoilers about to come up but if
you have seen Avengers end game enjoy
the trailer everywhere I go I see his
face just really miss him
damn isn't - I don't think Tony would
have done what he did if he didn't know
that you were gonna be here after he was
gone
you go me and next autumn and now well
no I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation
heads up Nick Fury is calling you I
don't really want to talk to any caste
resolved why because if you don't talk
to him and I have to talk I don't want
to talk about you sent Nick Fury to
voicemail I gotta go
you do not ghost Nick Fury dorks what's
up we're just talking about the trip I'm
here in San Marco Polo's oh I think MJ
really likes me when I first alone
you're a very difficult person to
contact spider-man this is mr. Beck
we're gonna use someone like you on my
world new world Beck is from Earth just
not out the snap to our hole in our
dimension we have a job to do you're
coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about Thor offworld captain are
unavailable that couch the friendly
neighborhood spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter I want to go back on
my trip with the girl who I really like
and tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
I always feel like I'm putting my
friends in danger the world needs the
next Iron Man you're going to step up or
not
[Music]
here girl them jet I work with
spider-man do one for spider-man I won't
win spider-man not for spider-man
you
[Music]
you